welcome to this video super cheese 7 yo
i played this this guy just recently and
i forgot what it was what kind of
opening it was or what kind of game I
had the route goes in recently was it
against the same player I don't know
Bishop Bishop age 4 is really sharp so I
know that this is not very ambitious but
I don't know the other stuff i really
don't i think i played this Bishop edge
for here in this exact position once a
new tournament game and lost really
really badly at least this is what I
remember ok wait I could have t25
actually why didn't I do that hmm not
that it necessarily was great but I
should have considered the move that
would be would have been probably a good
idea to just think about it you can
discard it anyway afterwards but you
should think about it ok so he claims
that this is a good structure for him
hmm yeah maybe was some justification a
form
complicated situation it's got this
advanced seep for porn my majority in
the center is not looking that valuable
and if he takes a pawn takes the b5 pawn
might easily be a weakness hmm this is
what I was thinking but it also
obstructed his development so maybe he
has to play or will play a 5 a 6 some
move some move like that and I'm
thinking about going 95 possibly four so
um yeah I'm going to t so he's willing
to allow look be seven but rook a one is
obviously very awkward okay so let's get
going here for temple thinking once in a
while would help it really would have
what else is it that I expected here
nothing really I really didn't think
about this it's actually a pure
coincidence that after f6 I probably can
take on c4 for a decent game getting two
pawns and the rook yeah I will I will
take care night back does this is
probably rubbish here I get get two
pawns um I get two pawns
and for rook and for the minor pieces
look n two points for 20 pieces yes um
let's see c4 c4 c5 yeah I should push
this maybe I should have considered this
a bit longer I'm okay rook a one okay
what if i take b6 now is this is this
worth considering check on c2 kingly to
TX takes a droopy one and have you 45
probably yourself I didn't plan anything
here in this game this is all happening
by coincidence actually I'm not saying
that this is brilliant but I didn't
really envision this to happen yeah and
this should be part of your planning end
up in the game to see some move once in
a while and plan it beforehand this is I
think quite good now I get the king over
to see 5 or to answer a dominant
position at least 2 d 4 + FY and stuff
that's it's really good for wide 4g 3f
form
now this is Pawn roller will be a huge
problem time
if probably should avoid f6 there I mean
maybe maybe this wasn't so terrible but
when he does not allow the whole thing
with 94 it's just in a very comfortable
state okay so as a c5 Jack Jack and now
should i do b7 here I played that for
for the pawns can also go easy six but
that's not so convincing
this is this is this is okay andy sixx
rook be seven en route be seven I can
even play d6 I think
check
you
and can run around here f 67 to promote
first being King Esau so King d8 and
King f7 then 4g have 47 black resigns I
was immensely lucky victory I really
didn't didn't plan properly in this game
I mean this is this is probably not that
terrible I mean I don't think the thing
is yeah I didn't take on b7 because here
he is just invading it looks it looks
really bad I did Jack me maybe this
method that that's really rubbish I
shouldn't take ok so I went 95 and I
really mean for some reason I didn't
really think about Bishop f5 that much
that it takes my rook I should probably
play Bishop e2 or something I mean he is
in goods in a good shape yeah but I
still should do that this is awkward I
still don't want to take on b7 because
of the invasion this is just a passive
move and now if he goes something else
like be five or maybe 97 b5 looks good
though it has to run anyway this point
and this and then f6 I mean this is
fantastic from like the I am fantastic
position and this is all of a sudden
allowing me back here Jack and see i'm
pretty pretty sure that i should be in
good shape but you know what is bad the
seafoam was bad now I should
the moment I'm controlling his tonight I
should start with this and then this
yeah and this is good two ponds is
really a lot looking two pawns against
to- yeah and TN and he's getting the
steroid come to play yeah does this look
a one business this was purely
coincidental I didn't really think about
it beforehand and chaplain and this is
so this is trickier this is a tricky
position I mean right definitely is at
least okay with the three pawns the way
it went I was more than okay but i
really don't know why why it went so
good i went here okay now played this
yeah this is maybe already a mistake
according to the engine the confirm that
the co but what but the comp wants to
play I don't get I know now I get it I
get it the computer wants to put the
bishop on b7 this is of course much
better yeah of course yeah it wants to
do this so that it can actually activate
the rook somewhere like but why not why
not this now I look a 6 ok a bishop a 6
i'm sorry before ok 8
or complicated yet complicated but black
kia is certainly better off then then he
was in the game this is this is clear
very interesting okay thanks for
watching